Lincoln suspended the writ of Habeas
Corpus a number of times during the
civil war.
And at first in 1861,
he suspended it first along the railroad
line between New York,
Philadelphia,
and Washington,
because there were riots going on in
Penn,
in,
in Maryland,
people trying to block troops coming
down to protect Washington.
So in a sense,
at first it wasn't a military district,
um,
and uh,
you know,
it was part of a war,
and later the writ of Habeas Corpus of
suspended for the whole country.
And certainly they were abuses of civil
liberties on the Lincoln.
No question about it.
People were arrested who just for giving
speeches,
criticizing the war,
they were newspapers temporarily
suspended.
Now we should not think that Lincoln was
a dictator,
a tyrant.
There was great criticism all through
the war of him.
And the elections went on.
Nobody said,
let's suspend the elections because you
know,
the war is on.
Um,
but certainly I think Lincoln
established a dangerous precedent that
the constitution doesn't really apply in
wartime.
And now,
unlike our recent president,
Lincoln directly address this question,
he went to Congress.
He said,
I may have stepped over the line here.
Here's my problem.
Here's my situation.
I was faced with this thing.
Do I abide by the law and let the whole
country fall apart or do I violate this
one law and therefore save the whole
country?
Well,
that's a difficult question to answer.
You know,
and there is no simple answer,
but at least Lincoln put it on the
agenda.
He said,
this is a serious problem.
President Bushes never even admitted
that as any kind of problem.
He just blindly goes his own way,
acting if there is as if there is no
constitution.
Um,
now the other thing is in the civil war,
the United States face the greatest
crisis in its history and the greatest
threat to its,
its existence as a nation.
Uh,
the attack of nine 11 was a tragic
thing,
but it didn't threaten the existence of
the United States.
And there is no thought that al Qaeda
today is actually going to overthrow the
government of the United States.
They can commit,
you know,
heinous acts,
but they,
they,
they're not going to take over the
government donald to Osama bin Ladin
will be president anytime soon.
So we don't face the kind of threat to
our national existence that Lincoln
faced.
Uh,
on the other hand,
history shows that almost any government
conducting a war,
we'll find the constitution and
inconvenience and we'll try to get
around it.
And this has happened during World War
One with the suppression of freedom of
speech.
It happened in World War Two with the
internment of Japanese Americans.
So,
you know,
what is the lesson?
It's simply that we have to be very
vigilant about our liberties and that
you,
you know,
to realize you can conduct a war and
still respect civil liberties.
Lincoln is saying,
and this is a democratic view,
if people think I have abused my power
or have not conducted the war properly
or intelligent leave,
they'll vote me out of power.
That's what democracy is.
It gives you a chance to boot the guys
out.
Uh,
and Lincoln ran for president reelection
in 1864,
and even though he won a very large
majority,
we should not forget that in August,
not long before the election,
Lincoln and most politicians thought he
was going to lose that the war was at a
stalemate.
There was a great deal of discontent.
Lincoln and the Republican Party thought
he was going to lose.
In fact,
there were people who came to and said,
you've got to rescind the emancipation
proclamation.
People think that it is prolonging the
war,
that if you tell the south,
come back and you can keep slavery,
they'll come back now.
But if you say,
come back and you've got to get rid of
slavery,
that is just making them fight longer.
So rescind the emancipation
proclamation.
Lincoln said,
I cannot do that.
I would be damned,
and time and eternity or something like
that.
In other words,
you know,
he wasn't willing to do quote unquote
anything.
He,
anything that might be done to get
reelected.
The problem with Lincoln's quote though,
is that in the midst of a war,
it often is quite popular to trample on
civil liberties.
You know,
many of the things that President Bush
has done,
if had popular support,
rounding up people with,
I'm Muslim names,
uh,
chucking them into jail with no charge,
throwing away the key holding people at
Guantanamo.
Um,
you know,
when people are frightened,
they are willing to support serious
infringements on other people's civil
liberties.
Civil liberties are not supposed to be
subject to popular vote.
They are in the constitution.
They are the protection of minorities.
The person who holds popular views,
his freedom of speech is never in
question.
It's the person who's the dissenter,
who has unpopular views.
So you don't put that up to a popular
vote to say,
well,
should this guy be able to give a speech
criticizing the war?
A lot of people say,
no,
we shouldn't.
So,
you know,
Lincoln's view of democracy in a certain
sense is right.
But on the other hand,
it doesn't really reflect the fact that
civil liberties are the protection of
minorities against majorities,
and therefore they can't be just
subjected to majority vote.